Luke what was it like working on
wastelands I had a great time it was oh
it was a lovely bunch of people and I
love being up in Leeds for five weeks
lovely city and yeah it was really good
there's a little bit about your
character and well appeal to about him
well Harvey is he's just come out of
prison and he's been put wrongfully
imprisoned by a sort of by Neil
maskull's character who set him up so he
forms a plan and gets his mates involved
to try and get his own back and to try
and kind of give themselves a better
chance of kind of a future in life
together as yeah you mentioned deal
masculine you've worked with him before
having you on recently on st. George's
Day was it like reunite reuniting with
him great I love Neil so much he's an
amazing actor such a great bloke to work
with and just a great play to have
around so yeah it's great and filming in
leaves tell me a little bit more about
what it was like up there it was it was
good it was good Matt's hometown so we
went you know he's he's an ambassador
for Yorkshire actually no less so we
kind of had the keys to the city now it
was good it was lovely yeah nice went
out on the moors it's beautiful
you